Hugo Lavallée.
- Compréhension.- Com.- Com.- C.
- La famille Cholakian
est arrivée au pays il y a
à peine plus d'un an.D'origine a
vécu en Jordanie
de choisir le Québec.
- La province, c- Tous ont suivr
cours de françai
d'immigrer, mais malgré ça,
l'intégration n'
de tout repos.
YERCHO CHOLAKIAN
- Le français, c'est une très
belle
c'est un peu difficile.
ARAM C
- Le premier jour, j'ai été à
l'accu
- Toute la famille s'est mise
'apprentissage intensif
du français depuis.
à temps plein, tandis que Yercho
wig suivent des cours
de français quotidiens.
la langue française pour
facilifacilifacilifacilifacilit.
- Carlos Carmona, qui travaille
la francisation depuisune quara,
constate que les immigrants qui
ou qui viennent de pays oùla lat
d'une certaine notoriété,
plus facilement.
CARLOS CARMONA, coordo.
organismes en francisation du Qc
de l'Est. Il y a des pays
en Amérique du Sud aussi
où le français a un certain
de ces pays viennent ici
au Québec et ils ont une
tendance aussi de s'intégrer
- Car apprendre la langue,
une fois installé, ne se fait
pas sans peine. Selon une étude
québécois de la langue
française, les deux tiers
des adultes qui ne parlaient pae
le parlent toujours pas 10 ans
plus tard. Le projet de loi 96
crée un nouvelle organisme :
il ne modifie pas les critères
de sélection des immigrants.
Or, pour de nombreux expertssems
en commission parlementaire,
l'avenir du français repose
autant, sinon plus, surimmigratn
renforcée que sur
un durcissement de la loi 101.
CHARLES CASTONGUAY, prof. math.
- La forte présence d'immigrante
française, qui connaissaient
avant d'immigrer au Québec,
a été un facteurntntntntntntnt
dans l'amélioration du pouvoir
d'attraction du français.xperts,
Charles Castonguay estime que
le gouvernement doit accorder
plus d'importance à
la sélection des immigrants.
Une me fait fait fait fait faitt
ses preuves autant sinon plus,
à son avis, que la loi 70.
- Avec les réfugiés haïtiens
qui fuyaient le régime Duvalier
ou encore les Vietnamiens,
la guerre au Vietnam, c'était
ancotropes et ils ont
effectivement, la majorité,
des immigrants dt francisés dèst
des années 70. Ça a rien
avec la loi 101.- Je vais juster
à quelques personnes de lire.
- Sur le terrain, on aimerait
es cours de
français plus rapidement.
Dans plusieurs o les cours
commencent en janvier, avril,
juillet et octobre de chaque
année. Les immigrants qui
doivent trop souvent attendre ar
leur parcours de francisation.
et il faut pas que la
personne... il faut pas que
la personne puisse se faire- Sut
français à leur arrivée ont plus
à long terme. Des immigrants
et 2019, 86 %
de ceux qui parlaient français
au Québec en 2021.
Contreeux
qui ne parlaient qu'anglais.
- Donc, apprendre le français..e
les pemencer
un processus de francisation
le plus tôt
- La famille Cholakian, elle,ene
son apprentissage du français.
officielle du Québec et sans
connaître le français, la vie va
être un peu difficile au Québec.